[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID BARRY: Heather Boushey
is executive director and chief
economist at the Washington
Center for equitable growth.
Her research focuses
on economic inequality
in public policy, specifically
employment, social policy,
and family economic well-being.
And her latest book, from
Harvard University Press,
"Finding Time The Economics
of Work Life Conflict."
The New York Times
has called Boushey one
of the most vibrant
voices in the field.
And Politico twice named her
one of the top 50 thinkers,
doers, and visionaries
transforming American politics.
Boushey writes regularly
for popular media,
including "The New York
Times," Room for Debate,
"The Atlantic," and Democracy.
And she makes frequent
television appearances
on Bloomberg, MSNBC,
CNBC, and PBS.
She previously served
as chief economist
for Hillary Clinton's
transition team,
and also as an economist for the
Center for American Progress,
the Joint Economic Committee
of the US Congress,
the Center for Economic
and Policy Research,
and the Economic
Policy Institute.
She sits on the board of
The Opportunity Institute,
and is an associate editor
of Feminist Economics.
She took her PhD in
Economics from The New School
for Social Research and her
BA from Hampshire College.
Please join me in
welcoming Heather Boushey.
[APPLAUSE]
Heather, thank you for coming.
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Thank you.
I always hate the bio
reading part at the event.
DAVID BARRY: I'm sorry.
HEATHER BOUSHEY: No, no.
It's always so like, oh golly.
DAVID BARRY: Well, I thought
would jump Right into it.
So you discussed
throughout the book,
that the success of our economy
involves more than just success
in the business sector, which is
a little different than the way
most people, both in the
business community and outside
of it, think of the economy.
Could you describe
for us your vision
of who the important
actors in the economy are,
and what this more
comprehensive picture means
for how we should think about
assessing a successful economy?
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Yeah,
happy to start there.
First of all, thank you so much
for inviting me here today.
This is really fun and just
it's a pleasure to be here.
And welcome to all of you.
And so in the book, I
talk a lot about thinking
about what's good
for the economy
and what we think actually
makes the economy grow.
And a lot of times when
you talk to people,
it really sort of transcends
political ideology.
When you talk to people about
what they think is actually
good for the economy,
you get this story
that is very much a
supply side story.
It's about well, when costs
are low for businesses.
When you know wages are low,
they can hire more people.
Or if there's less regulations
that mean that businesses
have to jump through hoops.
These are all things that
allow businesses to grow
and that therefore is what we
need to do as policymakers,
because that's what's
good for the economy.
And that all may
be totally true.
In fact, for any
individual business owner,
those are actually very
important questions.
You have to think
about your bottom line.
You have to think about how
you're running your business.
But when you step back
and think of the role
of what policymakers
need to be thinking about
or what economists
think about, you
have to think of not just that
narrow business perspective.
That's just one slice
of the bigger picture.
Right?
And so even sort of
thinking about the business,
it's like, an employer has to
think about where they're going
to get talented people to hire.
Those people don't just
emerge out of nothing.
They're created by
families, they're
educated in schools, there's
all of these institutions that
have to create that talented
labor pool for that employer,
so that they can actually have
somebody whose wages they don't
want to go too high to pay.
They also have to think
about whether or not
there's consumers for
whatever it is they're making.
And part of what businesses
do is try to figure out things
that people want to
buy, but they also
need people who
actually have money,
they can buy those things.
They need to have that
consumer base available.
And that we're talking
a lot these days
about the role of
trade in consumption.
So a one role a policy
has is whether or not
we allow people from other
countries to buy our goods
or whether or not
we import them.
That's a policy question
around consumption.
But it's also around the
well-being of families,
because families comprise
the vast majority
of end users of any of most
products produced in the United
States.
So, when you kind of step
back and look at this bigger
picture, there's a lot of
things that firms don't control,
but that are about
the institutions,
and the supply of people, and
consumer demand that sit around
what individual businesses do.
So if you want to
understand actually
what's good for the
economy, you have
to take that larger picture.
So in the book I talk about it.
That we need to think of
both families and firms.
And both of their
roles in the economy.
And the book is called Finding
Time, a lot of what it's about
is thinking about the conditions
under which people sell
their time to employers, and
the conditions under which
employers buy that time.
How those two interact that
it's not just the business
perspective, but that you
have to put both together
to really understand
what's happening.
DAVID BARRY: So if we,
up until this point,
haven't really considered the
family aspect of the economy,
it seems as though our picture,
or our understanding of how
the economy actually
works, is pretty skewed.
So what does this say about the
measures we're currently using
to judge our economy's health?
HEATHER BOUSHEY: That's
a great question.
So there's two points I
want to focus on in that.
One is that--
One of the things I really
struggled in with the book,
and struggled in,
in terms of thinking
about how to advise
policymakers,
is that when you
think about what
we learn in economics,
what economic teaches,
is so often the models,
I mean almost universally
the models start by thinking
about an individual's actions.
How is it that an individual
will act in the economy.
And that's an important
place to start.
But the reality
is, that most of us
actually do the majority
of our consuming,
and educating the
next generation,
and even thinking
about labor supply,
these decisions happen
inside families.
And there's certainly economists
that have thought about that,
but that sort of hasn't
infiltrated everything
in terms of how we think about
what's good for the economy.
So one, sort of starting place
for the question you asked
is that thinking about not
just for the individual,
but opening it up to really
think about the family
side of the equation.
To take a step back,
one of the things
that we watch every
quarter is the nation's
gross domestic product.
Right?
So that's the big
number that comes out.
One of the most numbers in terms
of measuring our economy along
with, I would argue,
the employment rate
that comes out on the
first Friday of each month,
and how our wages are doing,
and the income data that
comes out once a year.
But we watch this
GDP data and we
think it means something
about our economy.
Right?
So we know now that the US
economy produced $18 trillion
worth of goods and
services in 2016,
which is the largest of
any country in the world,
and is probably
actually therefore
the largest of any
country in any world ever,
right, because we're
growing over time.
But one question that
that doesn't answer,
that aggregate doesn't answer,
is, what does that actually
look like across families.
What does that actually
look like across America?
And there are scholars who are
digging into this question,
and sort of trying to understand
the connection between how
well the economy is faring,
and what that actually
looks like inside families
all across the United States.
And they're finding
that if you look
at economic growth
between 1980 and 2014,
the US economy grew
by 61% for every adult
in the United States.
So 1980 to 2014, 61% per
adult. But when you actually
match the data up
and look at what
that looks like inside
families, what you find
is that translates
into a 1% growth
rate for all adults living in
families making less than--
in the bottom 50% of
the income distribution.
So the economy grew
by 61%, but families
in the bottom half,
people in the bottom half
saw a 1% gain over
that time period.
While those at the top
saw these enormous gains.
The top 1% saw
gains of about 204%.
So when you open up and
you're not just thinking
about the business case.
You're not just thinking
about the traditional measures
we use.
You can get a deeper
understanding of what this
looks like across families.
That number on what growth
looks like across income
distribution, is
very important when
you think about what that
means for consumer demand.
So the economy is growing, but
most people aren't actually
gaining from growth.
We can't expect them to be
increasing their consumption
year after year after year
unless they are taking
on more debt, which is something
I talk about, how that affects
family economic security.
It also has implications for
the capacity for families
across the income
distribution, to be
able to educate the
next generation,
to be able to provide the
health and well-being and all
that we need that is
actually supporting
not only people, which
is certainly important,
but supporting our
future labor supply.
DAVID BARRY: Great, thank you.
So yeah, so that leads kind
of to the next question which
is, one thing you make
clear throughout the book,
is that the economics
of work life conflict
is not just a women's issue.
It's not just an issue
for professional workers,
or for low wage workers, really
it's an issue for everyone.
What led you to that insight?
And could you please
describe for the audience
briefly how you
segmented your analysis.
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Yeah, so
you know for a long time--
I started out--
I'm an economist and
I came to these issues
because my primary research
interest is understanding
the well-being of America's
families, economic well-being.
And so that's what I've
studied and sort of thought
about and over time one of
the most important trends
that we've noticed since
the 1970s that has affected
American families, is a movement
of women out of the home
and into the labor force.
It's had huge effects
on family income.
It's affected the
time families had.
So that was sort of my initial--
it's like, oh wow, this
is the important thing.
But when you think
about what that means,
to have people change how
they spend their days,
from spending it at home and to
spending it in the labor force,
that isn't just something
that affects women.
Right?
Certainly they're the person of
taking that different action.
Right?
They're actually changing
what they're doing.
But that actually then
affects everyone around them.
It affects their partners.
It affects their children.
It affects their communities.
It affects PTAs, League of
Women Voters, all the volunteer
things that women used to do.
So it affects
community institutions.
And it also affects care for
the aging and the elderly.
So all the different
activities that American women
used to do when they were unem--
not being paid in the
labor force, but at home.
As they've shifted their time.
It has these broader effects.
So that's, in a nutshell, why
this isn't a women's issue.
I mean it just so happens
that women are the people that
change what they do.
But it affects everyone.
And understanding why they've
changed their employment
patterns, and what that
means for men, and children
and for families
and their income,
is really the focus of the book.
I look at families.
I divide them into three groups.
I look at low income
families, families
in the bottom 30% of
the income distribution,
professional families
which I define as families
in the top 20%, where at
least one person has a college
degree.
So it's sort of
taking out families
that may be high
incomes but maybe
sort of either a self-made
or just a different kind
of professional experience.
And then the middle is
sort of the middle 50%.
So I talk about
what the economics
are of those families.
How they've shifted over time.
And then look at them as
three different groups.
DAVID BARRY: Great.
So I wanted to drill down a
little on each of the groups.
So first, take for instance,
the group at the top.
So what you call the
professional class,
that is soaring above
and sounding the alarm.
You, and I, and many
of us at Google,
are probably in
this category trying
to juggle work, family,
friends, and wondering
where fun fits in.
But that's not really the
whole story for this group.
Could you please describe
why the situation
for this group at the top,
indicates a larger problem?
HEATHER BOUSHEY:
Yeah, so yes I can.
So I also want to explain
the metaphor about soaring,
but I'm going to get
to that in a minute.
So just ping that and we'll
come back to that one.
So when you look at what's
changed for families over time
and this transformation of
how women spend their days.
What you see is, of course,
in professional families
and I'm guessing
many of us in here
have a sense of this, is that
families at the top typically
now have both men and
women in the workplace,
and no one at home full time.
So they have these two incomes
but still no one at home
to provide all the things
that families need.
You know, care for
children, the elderly,
waiting home for the cable guy,
whatever it is that families
need somebody to do.
And we hear a lot about
these families in the media,
more so than I think the middle
and the low income families,
because that way of living
can be incredibly stressful.
Our world isn't really set
up to have no one at home.
And so we hear a lot in,
especially on the style pages,
or in not necessarily always
on the business pages which
is where I think
it should often be,
but we hear about the
struggles that families face.
And fundamentally, it's that
there's a squeeze on time.
And so I think once you sort
of think about it that way,
and you start sort of
watching this conversation
that we're having as a country.
So much of it is that
families are really
stressed out because they're
squeezed for time, even
at the top.
Because money can
purchase some things.
It can purchase prepared meals.
It can purchase childcare.
But what it can't purchase,
is that family meal together.
Right?
If you actually
want to spend time
with your children, or
your spouse, or your loved
one, or your ailing mom,
like you actually still need
that time to do that.
And how to juggle that, when
you have two careers that
often take up very long hours.
So I talk a lot in
the book about how
we need to recognize what
long hours do to families,
and what the lack of access
to paid time off, paid family
leave, paid both parental
and family caregiving
leave, and access to high
quality affordable care means.
And that even for
families at the top who
can afford to outsource child
care, elder care whatever it is
that they need, there's
still that stress and anxiety
around it.
Yeah.
DAVID BARRY: Sure.
So then yeah.
Like take a look at the
lower end of the spectrum
now, the stuck low
income families.
So this group has
struggled for some time.
Have you noticed that something
has changed for this group?
And compared to the
group at the top,
is there something that's not
getting enough attention here?
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Yeah.
Well, in the book
I try to actually
lay out some parallels
between how we think
about the challenges for
professional families, and how
that also--
how you see similar challenges
for low income families.
Of course, they
look very different
because of resource constraints,
in low income families.
But one commonality is that
low income families also
don't have a full time
stay at home caregiver.
Just like families at the top.
But they're doing it
typically with one--
disproportionately they have
one caregiver, one parent.
If it's a family with children.
So they have one parent
and that parent also works.
So they also were struggling
with the time constraints,
that families at the
top are, but they're
doing it on one
earnings, you know,
rather than two, which
families at the top have.
So that's sort of one
commonality, where
I think we could be thinking
about the challenges
that low income families
face, and how that--
other solutions that might
hit both kinds of families.
Is sort of one of the things
that I'm always looking for.
How can we actually get
to some sort of action.
So one of the things that's
changed for low income
families, of course, over
the past half century,
has been this movement away
from stable family structures.
So it used to be that
the probability of having
two parents and a
stay at home mom
was much more similar
across families top, middle,
and bottom.
Certainly when we laid out
the basics of our nation's
social insurance and labor
protections in the 1930s,
It was a case that the
majority of families
looked like that, sort of
that traditional family,
even if they were
low income families.
And one of the things
that's been well documented,
is that alongside
rising inequality,
you've seen this rising
disparity in family structure.
And so families at the
bottom, increasingly
have unstable families.
Families that are mixed,
divorce, remarriage,
and the like.
And that is both chaotic, but
too often leaves families still
with no one at home
to provide care,
but still having
insufficient income.
So that's one big change.
The second of course, is
that jobs are changing.
And what you've been
seeing especially
among low income
families, is an increase
in scheduling unpredictability.
So alongside the fact that
incomes for low income families
pretty much haven't
grown since 1979,
you've seen this increase in
scheduling unpredictability.
Which makes it
hard to figure out
how you're going
to go to school,
or juggle childcare, any of
the things that you need to do,
if you actually don't know
what your schedule is more
than a few days in advance.
So that's one thing, and
then third, of course,
is the lack of income
growth that you've
seen for families at the bottom,
even though they have they
typically have this earner.
And in fact, for
low income families,
if you hadn't had that
increase in women's labor force
participation rates, and
the added wages of women,
family income would have fallen
much further than it actually
did between 1979 and 2014.
DAVID BARRY: Your last
group is the middle class.
You used stalled middle class
the way that you describe it.
What struck you most about this
group when you looked at them?
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Well,
it's the biggest group.
In the-- and this is sort of
the sword stuck and stalled
kind of metaphor.
In the book, I talk
about the middle class.
And I'm from Washington state.
I grew up near Seattle.
And in 1980-- and a lot of my
data started in 1979 so about
the same time--
Mount St. Helens blew up.
And that's a fact, we all
know that that's true.
But as an economist, one of
the most important charts
that you look at
if you're thinking
about the well-being
of family income
is this rise in family
income over time.
And if you look at it
between 1947 and 1979,
you see this straight up
increase in family income.
Just kind of like rising up at a
45 degree, it's not 45 degrees,
but rising up pretty
sharply, very nicely.
Kind of like moving up the
side of a beautiful mountain.
Right?
And then after 1980,
the chart changes.
So instead of going up, it sort
of kind of has this flatness,
and it's kind of a
little bit craggy.
And basically, every time
I look at that chart,
I think of Mount St.
Helens blowing up.
It looks like the top is
just blown, been blown right
off America's middle class.
And so that's what I think
is basically happened.
And one thing I talk about in
the book was an analysis that I
did, is that were it not for the
increase in women's labor force
participation and the
increasing women's earnings,
that family income which
for the middle class
has grown by about 12% between
1979 and 2013 or 2014--
I can't remember actually
what year the data stops--
but about then, about 12%.
Had it not been for the added
hours and earnings of women,
that small increase that
middle class families saw
would have actually
been a decline.
So it's only because of the
added labor force participation
of women, that you actually
see any increase at all
in middle class
incomes, since 1979.
So those families,
just like families
at the top and the bottom, are
struggling with the same issues
with the lack of time.
Women are working more.
Families don't have that full
time stay at home caregiver
anymore.
But the world has not
really adapted to this.
So crazily, we live in a
country where schools still
shut down for months at
a time, leaving families
having to negotiate summer care
and all these sorts of things,
even though you don't have-- we
don't sort of live in a farming
community, more where
that makes a lot of sense.
But that's just sort of one
kind of tip of the iceberg
example of all the ways that--
the fact that families
need the income of women,
at the top, the
middle, and the bottom.
That they're struggling
with this lack of time.
That we haven't really
integrated into our thinking,
well how do we help
families cope with this.
And then of course
throughout the book,
I talk about well, there
are economic implications
of not addressing this.
Right?
Because even though
families are working more,
they're doing so in a way that
they're really struggling.
And there are potential
downsides to the economy,
the lack of income growth
affects consumption and demand,
and the way that
we're failing to think
about the full gamut
of labor supply issues
means that we are actually
suppressing labor supply more
than we need to be, both
now and really risking
the next generation.
DAVID BARRY: Great, thank you.
And so you propose a
number of policy ideas
to address these
challenges, and you
point to states or cities
that have already implemented
and laid the foundation
for these policies.
Are any of these policy ideas
in particular, gaining momentum
either at the state and local
level, or at the federal level?
And are there any other policy
ideas that you didn't mention,
that you hope a state or local
area might experiment with?
HEATHER BOUSHEY: I love the
focus on state and local.
That's fantastic.
When I started
working in this area,
I started doing the
work around work life
issues in the mid
aughts, and at that time
we had to look a
lot abroad for ideas
and for what was happening.
By the time I finished the
book, there isn't a single idea
that I talked about in
there that isn't actually
in place somewhere in America.
Which every time
I think about it,
kind of gives me chills, because
it's an area of policy where
we've made a lot of progress
over the past decade in states
and communities.
And I think it's one
bright spot where
we've really pushed forward.
And I don't think that
gets enough attention.
So I'll talk about--
I'll get to some of
the state and local.
Let me sort of lay out
just that the big vision.
I divide the policies
into four groups.
And they're easy to
remember because it rhymes.
So there are policies for
here, there, care, and fair.
It's kind of cute, but whatever.
It helps me remember
it, so I know I
can like organize my thoughts.
So we need policies for
when we're here at home.
So policies around paid
family and medical leave
and paid sick days,
in particular.
You all are very
lucky, because you
live in the state of California,
which is the first state
to have implemented statewide
paid parental and family
leave, on top of a long standing
individual disability insurance
program.
There are now four states that
have paid family medical leave.
District of Columbia
has just passed it
and now we have to wait,
because we are not a state,
we have to wait for Congress
to determine whether or not
we can actually go
forward with the law
that we democratically passed.
But that's a different
lecture on states' rights.
And so there are places
that are moving forward
on paid family medical
leave, and there
are dozens of places that have
implemented paid sick days.
I know you all here at Google
have access to paid sick days,
when you get sick
and have the flu
and you can't come into
work, but the majority of,
especially of low wage
workers in the United States,
do not have access to
any paid time off at all,
let alone the right to stay
home when they have the flu.
So that's the
first area, and one
where we've seen a lot of
really exciting movement
at the state and local level.
And in fact in
November, two states
move forward on paid sick
days for their states,
requiring that employers provide
five to seven days of paid
sick days.
The second, is that
we need policies
for when we need to be
there at work, not at home.
And to make that
work for families--
and here in that
bucket I put things
like predictable
scheduling, making sure
that we have adequate overtime
protections, and protections
for part time workers,
and also the right
to request flexibility.
So in the United States
today, less than one
in ten, far less than one in
ten private sector workers
are represented by a union.
And millions of
people don't even
have the right to ask
their employer if they want
to have a flexible schedule.
And millions of people
don't know their schedule
more than a few days in advance.
Now I often don't know my
schedule more than a few days
in advance, so this also
happens to professional workers,
but we're paid a lot more money
than folks that work in retail
or in food service
you have to deal
with unpredictable
schedules, but have
to do it on a lot less income.
So these are places where
the legislation that we
have at the federal level,
the Fair Labor Standards Act,
it says nothing
about these issues.
I mean it says something
about overtime,
but it doesn't say
anything about overtime
for people that
are not production
workers, or salaried
workers, that you know,
which is a lot of us that
have no protections at all.
So we need to rethink what does
the economy look like today,
and how can we support families.
We need policies
around care, that
provide safe, affordable,
and enriching options
for care for children,
but also increasingly
the aging of the elderly.
There are very few
options for people
barring selling down
all of your assets
when you get older, to
provide some of the services
that many older folks need,
so that they can age in place.
And we haven't spent enough time
as a nation really figuring out
actually how to
address that, let alone
making sure that folks
have access to health care.
And then finally,
the fourth bucket
is issues around fairness.
Really making sure that as
we think about this basket,
making sure that these policies
are available to both men
and women.
That we're not discriminating
along the lines of gender
or anything else, because it's
the case that in a world where
most women are in
the workplace, that
means almost every employee
at some point in time
will have some reason that they
need flexibility or time off,
to provide care.
Be it for a child, or for a
friend, or for an aging parent.
And it's really important
to remember that for men,
not only is it really
important that they're there
in the early days of
having a new child.
Be it that through adoption
or becoming a new parent,
that there's a lot of evidence
just how important that time is
not just for moms but for dads.
But it used to be that if
a man's mom or dad fell
ill and somebody needed
to take care of her,
he had a stay at home
wife that could do that.
And of course now that's not
the case in most families.
And so both men and
women are having
to deal with needing
the flexibility to care
for an aging population.
And so really making
sure that we're not--
that we're recognizing that
this is a universal problem, not
just a problem for some people,
when they have new children
is really an important
piece of the puzzle.
So, a little bit
on state and local.
So as I said, there's been some
great work around family leave
and paid sick days.
You know California
has also been a leader.
San Francisco has been a
leader, especially in issues
around predictable scheduling.
So there's some
legislation that's
now in place in San
Francisco, around that
and a number of other
places in the country that
requires employers to give
notice on what an employee
schedule is.
There's also a lot
of economic evidence
that policies like
that are actually not
just good for the employee, but
they're also good for business.
So in much of the book as I
talk about this policy agenda,
I spent a lot of time digging
through the economic evidence,
to show that these policies
can improve labor supply, they
reduce employee turnover,
they increase retention,
they can stabilize demand.
That all of this is a
part of this conversation.
So it's not just
about the family piece
and how this is a nice
thing to do for people,
but that this basket
of policies, there
is just reams of
economic evidence
that would fill this
room, that makes the case,
that there are strong
economic benefits to doing so.
DAVID BARRY: I
think we can open up
to the audience for questions.
AUDIENCE: So I think there was
a lot of interesting policy
advice but what about individual
professionals such as ourselves
for balancing work and life.
What advice would you give us?
HEATHER BOUSHEY:
Oh, OK Well golly.
That's a tough one.
I assume that you
put in long hours
I think that for individuals--
I mean so-- it was the
for ourselves part, that's
kind of tripping
me up a little bit,
right, because there's people
who work for good employers
where they have good benefits
and feel that they can ask you
know-- they can go to
their manager and say, hey,
I need a little
bit of flexibility,
or I'd like to rotate
my schedule a little bit
and leave you know early
on Thursday afternoons
because I've got my kids'
soccer games or whatever.
But the reality is
it's so you know
the majority of American
workers actually don't even
have the right to do that
without fearing for their job,
that it's hard to give
advice sort of generally,
when I know that there's people
that may be watching this that
don't actually work at Google.
But I think to kind
of flip the script
and go and think about from
the manager's perspective,
I think one of the
most important things,
if you are a manager and
thinking about these issues is
recognizing that ultimately,
at the of the day,
your goal presumably is to get
productive work out of these--
out of your employees.
And there's just a lot of
evidence that providing people
with the flexibility
that they need,
and the time off they need
to recover, to make sure
that their kid
recovers from the flu,
all can be
productivity enhancing.
And all can do a lot
to reduce job turnover
and increase retention.
A number of years ago a
colleague of mine and I
looked at all the
good studies we
could find on the
cost of job turnover,
and what that looks like
across the wage spectrum.
Because you hear
like, oh yeah well,
job turnover can
be very expensive
if you have a very
important employee that you
have to replace
but for those line
workers, or those
retail workers,
it's nothing, it doesn't
matter like cost of turnover
is really low or something.
You sort of here that
in the common discourse.
So at any rate, we looked at
every study we could find,
and this was maybe almost
like eight years ago
that I did this so I'm sure
there's new studies that
have come out but, of all
the studies we could find,
we found that if you
look across people--
and again this was a while ago--
but people were paid from like
$20-$30,000 a year all the way
up to about $75,000 a year,
which in today's dollars would
probably be closer to about 80
or 90.
The cost of
replacing an employee
was about a fifth of that
employee's annual salary.
So as a manager, really
thinking about the fact that,
hey this person just wants
a little bit of flexibility,
and maybe they won't be
more productive this week,
but if the difference
between keeping
that employee for another
year or six months and not.
That actually has enormous
savings for the corporation.
And you know, too often,
that calculus of those costs
don't seem to be sort
of worked in to some
of these line manager
thinking, at least
according to the evidence.
So yeah, so that's some
advice I have for you
AUDIENCE: Can you also
talk about how expectations
of Americans in terms
of possessions, wealth,
average house size, which
has gone up I think something
like 1,000 square feet
in the last 30 years,
ownership of stuff
has also fueled this.
I feel like at times we're
putting this on ourselves
with the expectations we
now have collectively.
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Yeah
it's a great question.
So there's an economist from
Cornell named Robert Frank has
written a lot on consumption.
And so some of what
I am going to say
is stuff that I guess
that I learned from him.
It's a really important point.
One of the things
that economists
are learning about inequality,
like what does inequality
do to our economy
and our society.
One of them is
that you see people
trying to keep up with the
next rung just above them.
So there is this sort of these
consumption patterns start
to get ratcheted up because
there's this catching up
kind of phenomena that happens.
And then there's also
of course especially
over the past few decades,
an increased availability
of debt instruments that
are available to anyone,
that just were not available
30, 40, 50 years ago.
Right?
So we all have credit cards, but
also just the ability to get--
to have access to so
much ways of getting debt
that can boost consumption.
And debt's really interesting
because if your income keeps
rising, super easy to pay off.
Right?
And so if you're optimistic,
well in five or 10 years,
I'm going to be making
more so I can pay off
that mortgage or I
can pay off that car
or whatever, then that can
be a good way of closing
a short term gap.
But in a world where people
are trying to sort of keep up,
or where they feel that
they need to get that better
home no matter what size
it is in that better school
district because the
United States has this,
I'm sorry but
completely wacky way
of funding education,
public education, where
it's based on tax
dollars in communities,
so that richer communities
have better schools.
Right?
That creates enormous
pressure especially
in an era where it's
harder and harder
to get into the best colleges.
It creates enormous
pressure for families
to spend more than they need, to
kind of get to that next place
and then you've got these
debt instruments, mortgages,
and other that make it a lot
easier for families to do so.
Of course we've
learned, and we're
all I believe older
than the age of eight
so we all lived through
the financial crisis
and know the vast, horrible
repercussions of the nation's
where too many families have
been relying on debt in order
to make ends meet.
So I mean, embedded
in your question
is how to change people's
perceptions of what
the good life is.
And I think that's a
really important question.
One sort of, one caveat I
want to go back to a stat
that I said at the near the
beginning of the conversation,
which is that between
1980 and 2014,
the US economy has grown
by 61% for every adult.
That's a pretty nice
increase in growth.
But the bottom half of
the income distribution
saw a 1% increase.
So I hear you that
there's a lot of folks
and I think certainly
in the middle
to very top that are in this
escalation of consumption,
that for the vast majority
of American families,
I think they are
probably rightfully
frustrated that
somebody is getting
the money from the
gains at growth
and it certainly is not them.
And so, how much are
people using debt
as a way to compensate?
Like oh, I'm sure I'll get
that pay out next year.
I don't know and I
can't speak to that.
But I do think that
these are twin problems.
And one certainly that it would
be good to keep talking about
AUDIENCE: Question
on the policy on pay
for care and other things.
How do you prevent people
from abusing the system?
HEATHER BOUSHEY: For
like paid family leave?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Yeah, so
that's a great question.
So first off, what you
have here in California
is this longstanding temporary
disability insurance program
and there is a agency
that administers that
and you know ensures that if
somebody says that they're
sick, it has to be verified.
So there's rules in
place to verify it.
And when you add the paid
family and parental leave,
I mean it's super easy
to verify whether or not
somebody has a child, has a new
child coming into their family
through adoption or birth.
But for the care, like
care for the elderly,
or care for someone
who is seriously ill,
it can be a little bit more
difficult to verify that.
The federal law
that we have that
provides unpaid leave, which
is the Family and Medical Leave
Act, has a verification
process in it.
And the way that they do
it, is that your employer
is because you are
absent from work,
so the employer is the one that
knows that you're not there.
The employer has the right to
ask you for a doctor's note,
ask for some verification.
They don't have to, but they
have the right to do that,
to insure.
So if we moved to a federal
paid family leave, family
medical leave
program, we can learn
from what's happened in the
States that already do that.
So we could learn
from what, you know
how they make sure that people
comply here in California,
and in the other states
that have that program.
New Jersey, New York,
and Rhode Island.
And we can learn from what
we know from the Family
and Medical Leave Act.
I will say also, there's
a lot of incentive
on the part of
employees to not lie
to their employer
about important things.
Again, the vast majority-- the
share of private sector workers
that are represented by a
union that have job protection,
is 7%.
So the vast majority
of American workers
don't have the right
to keep their job.
And while they may get
the right to this benefit,
employers certainly
have a lot of leeway.
Somebody is going to lie to you
about this is probably not--
there may be other
performance issues,
so I actually have a high
degree of confidence,
that the research
that we've seen
that shows that there isn't
a great degree of lying about
the-- around issues
like around leave,
is because most people are
honest with their employers,
because they know that if
they aren't a good employee,
that they can lose their job.
So I think that, in and of
itself, is probably the best--
we already have this really
great defense against people
abusing the system.
AUDIENCE: I know the
universal basic income
is a big thing globally
and potentially locally
as well, I mean does that change
the equation of the groups
or any of these circumstances?
HEATHER BOUSHEY:
It's a good question.
I always hear a lot about
universal basic income
when I'm in California.
It's fun to talk about.
So it depends, I mean
so I think there's
a lot of different
ideas, like when
you say that it's like
one of these tests.
What do you mean when
you say that, right?
So one vision is that we
would give every American
a check for some amount of
money and so it wouldn't really
be really we're
placing any benefits,
it would just be some sort
of dividend for everyone.
Another vision
and it's certainly
what the United States thought
about, the Nixon's family
assistance program
from the 1970s,
which was a basic
income guarantee,
was a way of really providing
a basic income so that everyone
in America would not fall
below some threshold levels.
So you could set some level
and say OK if you're poor,
you know here's
this basic income.
So I think that might more
interact with policies
around welfare, or food stamps,
or the Earned Income Tax
Credit, probably actually
the Earned Income Tax
Credit, mostly would I
think be mostly affected
if we started to think about
a universal basic income
as a basic income for folks
that don't have a lot of income.
And so I don't know so I
think it really-- that to
me really is more about that
basic standard of living,
whereas a lot of these policies
aren't so much about folks
that don't have enough
to make ends meet
or who aren't working.
This is an agenda
for how does it
that you make sure that you can
actually get people to work,
and get them to work
in a way that's healthy
and they're productive
and they're ready to go.
And so conceptually, I think
it belongs in a different box.
Right?
Because even if you
have a basic income,
that's not going to solve some
of your work life conflicts.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I was
interested to hear
that a lot of the policies
that you describe in your book
are being tried
in various states.
So it's nice to have lots
of little experiments.
What would you say about
the strength of the evidence
for the different policies?
And for the ones that have
really strong evidence, what
are the big things that
are preventing them
from being more widely adopted?
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Yeah,
that's a fun question.
Some of them don't
have any evidence,
very much yet because the
policies are very new.
So I would say on the stable
schedules legislation,
we don't have evidence yet.
And in fact my organization
the Washington Center
for Equitable Growth, we
give grants to scholars.
And we've been thinking a lot
about the scheduling stability
piece, and how we can study
that and learn more about it.
And we've funded a pilot study
that a couple of our scholars
did with the gap, to
understand their move
toward stable scheduling.
And we've learned a lot.
We're learning a lot from that.
The gap is actually
felt that it's
been quite effective, in
good for profitability,
and good for productivity.
And they've actually moved
forward on the policy.
So we have some evidence
from some employers,
but we don't have
evidence from a policy,
from a state or local
government yet on that issue.
There's two I want to touch on.
One is on the child early
childhood development,
and one on paid leave.
And so on paid
family medical leave,
we actually know quite
a bit about California.
There were some in-depth
studies done in California
around the implementation of
the paid family medical leave
program here.
And so we know, for example,
that 90% of employers
in this survey reported that the
implementation of paid family
medical leave here
in California,
actually had no effect
or a positive effect
on profitability
and productivity.
That they didn't.
So only 10% reported
any downside at all
to the implementation.
We also have good evidence on
what it did on the effects--
on how it boosted
family incomes.
We also know from that
research that a lot
of people who are eligible for
paid leave here in California,
haven't taken it.
Disproportionately those
are low income folks
who don't have job protection.
So the paid-- so the federal
Family Medical Leave Act,
gives you job protection to
take up to 12 weeks of leave
to care for a new
child, an ailing loved
one, or your own illness.
Only about 60% of
the labor force
is covered, however, because
if you haven't been at your job
long enough, or if you work
for a very small employer
you're not covered,
among other reasons.
So a lot of the folks that
didn't take it in California,
they didn't do it
because they were
afraid of losing
their jobs or being
punished by their employer.
So that's a really
important data point.
So we know a lot from
California and Equitable Growth
has also funded some work
looking at other states.
So we're learning
a lot from what's
happening in Rhode Island,
New York and New Jersey that
have implemented that program.
Paid sick days, which I
wasn't going to talk about
but since I'm here
in California.
San Francisco was one
of the first places
to implement paid sick days.
And economists
went in and looked
at what the outcome was on
employment, in San Francisco
and the surrounding counties.
Because one of the
arguments was, OK,
if you give people the
right to earn up to,
I believe it was seven days
of paid sick days in San
Francisco, then that'll
be a job killer.
Right?
Obviously, people are going
to get laid off for that.
That was the argument
that you heard.
And in the book I
have some great quotes
from employers who said that
before the legislation passed.
But what these
economists found was
that actually after the
legislation was put in place,
employment in San Francisco
grew faster than the surrounding
five counties in
like a year or two
after the implementation
of the policy.
And I am in no way saying that
the implementation of paid
sick days caused the
greater employment gains.
But it's a very difficult
threshold then to make
the argument-- and this has been
replicated in other places--
it's very difficult to make
the argument that giving people
paid sick days pulled down jobs.
When in fact, what
happened was the opposite.
And this has happened
in other places as well.
We have a similar study
in Seattle and in DC.
And then on early
childhood, there
is overwhelming
evidence at this point
that not attending to
the years between 0 and 5
has lifetime implications
for children.
And again going to the economic
angle to our future labor
supply.
So we knew that the skills that
children enter kindergarten
with, and the gaps
between children
that have skills and
don't have skills,
stay with them over a lifetime.
And it's very difficult,
if not impossible,
for later educational
interventions to really make up
for those this early gaps.
And yet we live in a
world where most women
have their first child
before the age of 26.
Young people don't
have a lot of income.
They don't have access
to high quality care.
And we do virtually nothing.
We do some things for
very poor families,
but we're not doing anything
for the vast majority
of middle class families who
are really struggling to provide
that high quality care.
There is probably
no other investment
that we could make in
America's future that
would have as big a
bang for the buck,
as investing in universal
child care and universal Pre-K.
AUDIENCE: The second
part of the question
was for policies like child
care policies, what's preventing
their adoption more widely?
HEATHER BOUSHEY:
Right of course.
The grumpy part of the question.
Where, you know, the why
isn't that happening?
So yeah, of course this is so
great, why isn't it happening?
So I mean I will
say a few things.
I mean one is that you've seen a
lot of employers moving forward
in implementing these
policies, where they can.
So that's a sign that people
are getting the message on this.
Not nearly enough
and not across all
of their workers, which
I think is a problem.
Second, I do want to stress that
this is one area where you've
seen really remarkable social
change over the past decade.
So even amidst a lot of
lack of progressive movement
in places around the
country on policies,
this is really a bright spot.
We've implemented universal
social insurance programs
in four states, in
the past decade, which
is an amazing accomplishment.
So, and then it's passed
and a couple of others
but hasn't been implemented yet.
So I think that there is
a lot of forward momentum.
And then all the
places that have done
paid sick days and the like.
And places like DC
and other places that
have universal Pre-K. We
have free universal Pre-K
in the District of Columbia.
So I think that's positive.
At the federal level,
I mean certainly what
you see is these
issues, like all issues,
have been affected by the
continued polarization
and gridlock.
But what I will say is that
the 2016 campaign cycle
was the first one where you saw
presidential candidates on both
the left and the right
come out in favor
of pieces of this agenda.
So you had Marco Rubio,
Republican Marco Rubio,
who came out with a
paid leave program.
You had Secretary Clinton
who had a full agenda on all
of these issues.
You had Bernie Sanders who
signed onto the Family Act,
to provide paid
family medical leave.
And you had now
President Trump who
came out with policies
around child care
and maternity leave
during the campaign.
And then on Tuesday in
his speech to Congress,
actually talked about
paid family leave
and paid parental leave.
So and he-- and I actually
can't remember if he--
I believe he also mentioned
childcare is a part of his tax
program as well.
So you're actually seeing
these bubbling up and getting
traction across the aisle.
So I actually think of all
of the different policy areas
that I can work on
as an economist.
I actually think
this is probably
one of the most hopeful ones,
where there is a greater,
the greatest potential
to really see
the kind of transformational
change over the next decade,
because you've seen
it in so many places.
So, and then why hasn't
it moved as quickly.
I actually think that
it's been good to see
these policies implemented
at the state and local level,
so folks like myself and people
I work with could actually
take the time to study
it, and know what works
and what doesn't, at the
laboratories of democracy
kind of idea.
And I think we're
getting to a place
where we know so much
about some of these,
that we really are ready to
move those at the federal level.
So we will see.
I'm not terribly
optimistic that these
are going to be prioritized
by this Congress,
but hope springs eternal.
AUDIENCE: Have you studied the
opposite phenomena of families
trying to combine a quality care
and more time for the family
by moving out of
the salaried work
place into consulting or
even into to home child care.
HEATHER BOUSHEY:
So when you look
at the overall trends
in labor supply,
you see a flattening off since
the late 1990s for both men
and women.
Of course there
was the deep dive
during the Great Recession,
and then bubbling back up.
But the United States now
has lower labor supply
than most of our economic
competitors in the OECD.
We used to be among the highest.
Now we're among the lowest
for both men and women.
So that may be kind of
connected to your question,
that folks are unable to sort
of deal with the conflicts
around work and life, you know.
I tell in the book a lot of
stories of people in their 50s,
in later life who end up
dropping out of the labor force
to care for an ailing
parent, and then
find it really difficult
to get back in.
So maybe they do part
time work, or they
take on some consulting,
or some bits and pieces.
The stories-- I
mean I think what
I see because a lot of that
is happening at the lower
end, at the middle to
bottom, it's less about, oh,
this is great for me.
It's more about, oh well,
this is really all I can do,
given my situation.
And because I can't find an
employer that will be flexible.
So I think there's a
negative story there.
But I think certainly,
and this gets
to the question over
here about consumption,
you certainly see
some conversations
at the top about how
much families need,
and can they downsize, and
can they kind of pare back
to deal with some of
these care issues.
And I don't think you--
so you don't see a pulling
back in labor force
participation,
but you see a leveling
off of the increase.
So it may be that
those folks that,
were we to have this
kind of policy agenda,
might actually increase
their labor supply,
aren't actually doing so.
So that's an effect as well.
But it's not actually a
pulling back, but a flattening.
DAVID BARRY: Right, well great.
Thank you everyone for coming.
Thank you, Heather.
HEATHER BOUSHEY: Thank you.
DAVID BARRY: For coming
to Google, great.
HEATHER BOUSHEY: This
is very fun thanks.
[APPLAUSE]